e.d i want to go right back to you with
that
fight scene issue you had because again
we're paying money to see
monsters fight nobody on this panel is
disagreeing with that
but you didn't like the way that it was
lit you just felt like it was too dark a
la
the complaint a lot of people had with
that game of thrones battle scene
in the last season where you just
couldn't make out what was happening
yeah that was the biggest problem is
that if they're they're all
in the rain they're all in the dark and
so you're seeing these monsters like
collide
and then they'll cut to a shot of a
human like running away from them
and then they cut back to the monsters
and like maybe one of them is taking a
slow
swing and then they cut back to the
human and i'm like look
uh you have all of these monsters these
classic monsters
and give us more monster moments like i
i get
you know godzilla ripping like
ghidorah's head off and eating it
at the end i'm all four and i just
wanted like six more of those moments
in this film like give us some like
gnarly
monsters monster stuff monsters mortal
kombat
that's what this movie should be yeah so
more like goo
like give us like some ooze like some
real nasty oohs like somebody's like
arm getting like ripped off and then i
want to see one monster eat it and
another monster like drink ooze out of
an
arm like give us some like crazy monster
madness you know that's that's what
that's what we want to see
and it's just every every single action
sequence
is either underground in some monarch
cave there's like 70 of them in this
movie
or you know or they're outside in the
dark in the rain
and you know even there's a bolt of
lightning every once in a while and you
get like a money shot that looks like
it's like the
the middle of a graphic novel and i love
some of those shots
but they're just like still images
they're just like gifts
you know and that's it there's nothing
else there
and so yeah sorry i
feel like the a lot of the the darkness
seems to make sense not
just for the overall tone of the movie
that all these creatures have been
hibernating and really didn't feel like
waking up in their nap but humanity
demanded it and so
it's like when any one of us get awoken
by the dog or a kid
at 3am we put on our slippers we go out
we're like okay what the hell is it now
we're not necessarily in prime shape to
fight and godzilla really doesn't
bring his a-game until the second half
of this movie because godzilla shows up
and it's exciting
and promptly gets the crap beat out him
a couple times and sometimes the
the the shiniest point of light in these
fight scenes
is when godzilla starts to do his
hulking up nuclear tail thing which is
just one of the most kick-ass things
i've seen in a theater in the last
millennia but jacqueline if we're
pivoting from
fight scenes and you say the fight
scenes aren't the biggest issue you have
with this movie
i think i can go out on a limb and say
yeah the humans need to figure their
stuff out quicker so that we can get
back to
maybe better lighting with the monster
fights yeah i mean not even the better
lighting like
it just like the the first scene where
you figure out
why the woman uh why the mom is
freed the creatures like that very early
on scene where they're both on
like telelinks like she's in one of the
hideouts and they're in one of the
hideouts
two hideouts for one scene that that's a
that's a feat right there
and the thing that just struck me about
how stupid and pointless
all of these are is when millie bobby
brown like comes in there and like
there's her dad and she like pops in
hi dad i'm sorry and then pops out
and that's it that's all she has and
then the woman does her exposition
and she tells the story of the stupid
monsters i'm like why
why why why and it's so boring i miss
the jokes i give me some cheesy jokes
give me
what was the what was the two science
dudes in pacific rim
for like the comic duo like give me them
give me that i'll i will be all about it
what's his name from always sunday in
philadelphia and the british guy
i would love some of that comedic moment
[Music]
you